all right well uh let me welcome
you know the audience stalwarts who came
out for the
i guess you could say resurrection of
the philosophers in the midst of history
quarterly series this is something that
we started in 2016 by invitation here at
the frank weinberg library and then as
all of you know we got put on hold by
covid we got one session in
in 2020
right before all the lockdowns and stuff
like that happened
and so we haven't done anything since
until today
i'm happy to be back here even though
masked up we'll see how
well things go when we can't really
see each other's uh
faces that well
for those who who are interested you
know the previous sessions are video
recorded and available in a playlist in
my channel
i know most of you those who
are new to me i'm greg sadler
i'm a philosopher by profession and i
kind of split my time over three
main areas i teach as an you know
academic philosopher
now mostly just at milwaukee institute
of art and design
used to teach at marquette used to teach
at milwaukee area technical college
still teaching at carthage but i think
that is probably
coming to a
a close
but i also do a lot of what we call
public philosophy and that's that's part
of what we're doing today
and i would say that the guy that we're
going to talk about plutarch
he also did public philosophy so that
might be a topic that we we talk about a
little bit
um and then i have my own company reason
i o i do
ethics consulting
tutorials philosophical counseling and
stuff like that
so as we were actually talking about
just before we got started
this series it's a quarterly series and
we um we split it up so
in the very beginning the spring
not quite spring winter into spring
february we're doing ancient philosophy
and then we look at medieval thinker
sometimes philosophy sometimes you know
something else
then we do early modern and then we do
late modern so we've covered a lot of
people in ancient philosophy we did a
session on aristotle actually that was
the first session for this and we talked
about his relationship with alexander
the great and
how those things figured in together
with plato we talked about athenian
democracy
with epictetus we talked about slavery
and the roman empire we also did a
session on cicero we did a session on
epicurus and so today we're going to be
doing some ancient stuff as well but
i'll give you a preview of what's coming
up for the rest of the year
in the medieval time
we're going to talk about the the very
important early franciscan author
bonaventure a lot of people don't know
that the franciscans had a kind of
contentious beginning you could say and
bonaventure was one of the people who
smoothed things out
in in that and then we're going to talk
in the fall about hegel
george garg friedrich wilhelm hegel
somebody who i do a lot of work on
and then
i thought this year for finishing up in
winter you know provided we get there
i would do a presentation on somebody
who i did my dissertation on this guy
maurice blondell who isn't particularly
well known but was a very important
french
catholic philosopher from the late 19th
century to the early 20th century died
in 1949
made a lot of really important
contributions hi come on in
and so you know we'll do that but today
it's going to be plutarch and ancient
philosophy and you know if you think
about plutarch in the present
um
you know how do most people actually
encounter plutarch i should say
something too
those of you who've been here you know
this already you can you can interrupt
me at any time and ask a question or
something like that we can always get
back on track
and i often like throw questions out so
here's the first one
uh those who've read plutarch what did
you read
what did you what did you encounter
of plutarch it probably wasn't the the
you know on restraining anger or
something like that go ahead it's like
my reference to him is like his historic
history
yeah
that's right
mike's a great man
yeah the the parallel lives right
um we often assign them to high school
students or college students we don't
usually make them read all
23 of them
but because that's a lot but you know
they they wind up
reading them and it's usually done in
the context of either literature or
history which makes good sense
um plutarch wasn't writing histories in
the sense of
you know just the facts ma'am and
you know a lot of meticulous
documentation or anything like that he
had a different kind of project that
we'll talk about but
you know he was writing history he was
preserving it
and i actually heard about him in high
school and i i avoided them i didn't
want to read plutarch because that's
what the nerds were reading you know and
i didn't want to be a nerd in high
school i was taking ap classes but you
know i was also you know wearing a
leather jacket and had long hair and
stuff like that so i didn't want to you
know be carrying around books that would
damage my reputation or anything
and you know plutarch also wasn't
writing like sci-fi or fantasy or things
like that so i wasn't super into that
and you know for some reason we didn't
read him at all in college
and i also didn't read them in graduate
school when i went to study philosophy
and we'll talk a little bit about
that in just a minute
um so the way that i wound up reading
cicero was i've got this lobe edition
of his moralia
book six and this had a particular essay
in it that i wanted to look at on
restraining anger because i was doing a
lot of work at the time on anger
management as found in ancient
philosophy you know in aristotle or in
the stoics or plato
plutarch was actually a pretty important
person for that so
i i started reading him for that
and you know looked at him for the
virtues and vices and the more that i
read i was like wow this guy's really
got a lot to offer he
he isn't the
derivative
doesn't have anything original to say
kind of person that people have made him
out to be
i've been missing out and then there was
another work that we're going to talk
about in a little bit
called the
symposiacs or table talk
and it was about um drinking parties
drinking parties and dinner parties you
know you think about when we go to
dinner parties um what do people are
what are people supposed to be doing at
dinner parties sometimes they get in
fights sometimes they watch tv but what
are what are they actually supposed to
be doing you know
what's what's the the goal of a dinner
party i mean eating good food right
what's that conversion conversing yeah
having conversations and this this goes
all the way back to
um
maybe dinner parties that plato was
referencing in plato's symposium and
xenophon also writes about this these
are students of socrates so we're
talking about
you know the 4th century
bce and you know that continued on
people were like
it's cool not to just get blind drunk at
a party because that's what symposia
were before that everyone would just get
together and get totally blitzed
so then they start talking and they find
oh it could be fun to chat about stuff
come on in
to you know have some good food some
good wine
but primarily to enjoy conversation with
each other that's that's what they were
engaged in and so plutarch has an entire
book that's like
this this long
of all these conversations not is are
they all
verbatim no
he writes them down later on and he'll
he'll mention things about people you
know when when this guy came to visit
uh we we had this to eat and then we got
into this conversation we started
talking about the spartans or we started
wondering about god and fate or we
started you know talking about the
latest thing happening in rome
that's pretty fascinating stuff to read
and i was doing a project
that eventually culminated in a talk at
the culinary institute of america
about symposia saying well why don't we
do you know these kind of drinking
parties anymore
and plutarch turned out to be a very
valuable source for what these kinds of
parties looked like back in his time
and you know so i i got interested in
him and i'm kind of a a big fan of
plutarch i think he's what we could call
undervalued stock when it comes to
not just biography and history but but
philosophy i think he's he's actually a
good philosopher
of the ancient world but you notice and
this might be something that we want to
talk about a little bit later
if you go to a philosophy department
it's really
rare that you're going to find anybody
teaching plutarch or talking about him
let alone specializing in him i mean
it's more common like say in a classics
department or maybe
somebody in history or literature might
do it but he he was a philosopher so why
don't we focus on him
there's a whole story to tell there and
some of that we'll get to in the end
when we talk about his influence and why
it was so massive
and then why it went into decline
it's a similar story to
that which we can
bring up with other what we call
hellenistic philosophers right so you
got plato and aristotle early on
and there
considered to be very important um
they're the ones who are doing the real
work and then we have all of this stuff
that comes after them you know other
platonists and
the great hellenistic schools of
skepticism and stoicism and epicureanism
and later aristotelians and people like
plutarch himself along the way and
people like cicero
and that's that's all kind of you know
second rate that's that's a popular way
of looking at philosophy and its history
and that's a very new way that goes back
to the beginning of the 19th century
and kind of you know captures the
academic approach but that wasn't the
way that anybody looked at it before
that
so we'll we'll talk about that later on
why plutarch got caught in that
little trap
so what i want to do
today
is um
basically three things then we'll
probably have a lot of conversation and
and back and forth about things and and
again we can we can have conversation
during the middle of it feel free to
interrupt me at any time and ask
questions or raise objections or
whatever you want to do
so we'll talk about his history
where he is in history and culture and
you know why he was doing the things he
did and why he was considered important
then we'll talk about his actual
philosophy where he fits in to the um
the philosophical schools of his time
plutarch is considered to be
one of the most important middle
platonists
now if you don't know a middle platonist
is that that's fine we're going to cover
that
but you know when you're considered to
be the top that's that's pretty
important so we'll talk a bit about how
he figures in and then some of his ideas
and then i want to talk about his
influence
because he had massive massive influence
from the renaissance onward in the west
i don't know that much about his
influence in the east uh where they
could read him in greek and they had the
texts
in part because i'm not a plutarch
specialist and i don't i don't work in
byzantine philosophy but i do know this
he was important there too
so
that's what we'll talk about
with plutarch and with his history
we have a few dates
usually in the past i would create i
would give you another handout besides
just like his his text and it would have
like a whole timeline and it would say
like you know this happened this time
this happened this time and it would
like correlate plutarch and what he's
writing
to um all the other historical events
the reason i didn't give you one is
because we have very few
hard and fast dates for the guy
we're not even quite sure exactly when
he died we think it was around 120
but some historians say no i could have
been as late as 125.
so you know that that's a lot of wiggle
room i think
we we know he was born in 46
in uh cairo neo this this town that's
kind of a you know i don't want to say
podunk town because that's a little bit
too pejorative but it's not a really
important place
and it's in a part of northern greece
called boetea
the boy's hands were you know
traditionally viewed as being kind of
the rum dums of ancient greece you know
always ready to fight um by that time
that reputation had kind of gone away
you know we're talking about much much
later than plato or aristotle or any of
those people
not too far from delphi
you probably know that as an important
reference and plutarch is going to be
associated with delphi
he goes to athens in 66 and 67
studies philosophy mathematics rhetoric
at an academy there with a philosopher
who we don't know that much about
ammonius
as a matter of fact some of these
philosophers in his life they might be
one guy they might be another guy
we're not always quite sure which one is
which
and then he um
he travels he goes to rome he goes all
over greece
he does a lot of you know interesting
things
uh probably around 90 or so he returns
to carinea
and there's good reasons why he's going
back there
he may have been visited by the emperor
trajan in 113 he was granted a um
procuratorship
of aca by by the emperor hadrian who's
who's quite important one of the good
ones you know
if you know roman history there weren't
a lot of good emperors hadrian was
considered one of the good ones right
um
i think the dies maybe 122 125
we're not we're not exactly sure
but we don't we do know a lot of stuff
about his life and we also know a lot of
stuff about
rome and greece at the time
so that might be where to start
this is at a time when the roman emperor
roman empire has
essentially supplanted all the other
political alternatives of the time right
so you almost can't think of a a
different way of existing it's sort of
like you know when people think about
uh the america of today right where the
world's sometimes they used to call us
back in the early 2000's the hyper power
not just a super power
we uh when it comes to military power we
outrank everybody you know we've got the
aircraft carriers
we're still the largest economy although
china is pretty close
that's you know it's it's hard to think
of america going away
but that's the way they looked at the
roman empire the romans had managed to
beat the carthaginians the other people
in italy they defeated
pirates of appearance they'd conquered
all sorts of
successor states that were left over
after alexander of macedon had made his
conquest and then you know left
generals behind who took over in
macedonia some of the greek city-states
had you know succumbed to that and then
become independent again like sparta
athens
and you know they're all this fighting
that's that's going on
and um
it doesn't affect plutarch all that much
because a lot of this fighting is done
and things can
be we could say normal right trade can
go on and people can travel back and
forth there's wars against you know way
up north against those german barbarians
that are happening and there's always
wars with those persians uh over in the
east
one of the other great empires right of
the time
but for the most part things are you
know
pretty uh peaceful some of the greek
city-states had been given
back some relative autonomy
which they usually you know
misused
as you can guess they'd sometimes fight
against each other and then the romans
would have to come in and be like listen
guys we're we're done with all of that
you know this is this is the nobody
actually said this but i'm going to be
kind of facetious this is the pox romana
you know why don't you just like stick
to your literature and trading and
having dinner parties and stuff like
that and you know leave the fighting to
us um
your your glory days of fighting are
long past
obviously nothing like that ever
happened but it's kind of a funny thing
to imagine
and so plutarch has this opportunity to
travel around
to study things um this guy ammonius who
he studied with plutarch wrote a
biography of him we we don't have that
anymore so we don't know that much but
he was clearly an expert in aristotle's
works but he may have also been a
platonist like plutarch was
um
plutarch at one point in time becomes a
priest a priest of delphi
and that's pretty important it's not
just you know being prestigious
he thinks that delphi
really matters
in part because he thinks that
the oracles
can actually tell you something valuable
but there was something else at delphi
that was really important for philosophy
there when you would go into the temple
there are these delphic maxims and you
know the two most important ones for
philosophy
know thyself gnology see out to right
that's that's written on the temple
and then maiden agan no nothing too much
stick to the middle part but there were
all these other inscriptions and they're
all like little bits of wisdom like that
and they could give you some idea about
how you should live your life if you
could
unpack them if you could do more than
just trot them out as a quote if you
could actually figure out what they
they meant that was quite helpful
so that's important for him
he also had a home life
he has a couple brothers you know
um he's quite friendly with them they
show up at his dinner parties as we find
out in in the accounts um he is uncle to
somebody uh who
his name is sextus he he will become one
of the teachers of marcus aurelius the
famous stoic roman emperor
so he's got you know some some
significant pull
he and his his wife um appear to have
had one daughter who died young very
young and we know that that um
she died because he writes a consolation
to his wife about this saying ah this
you know consolations are basically
saying
death really sucks
but there's these other things about it
that are okay like she didn't have to
get old you know she didn't have to
suffer like like the rest of us and
she'll be reincarnated as something
something nice you know because she she
didn't have a chance to screw up
um
not like the rest of us right
he had four sons or they had four sons
two of which died pretty young in
childbirth
two of which survived and you know we
learn a bit about them not too much
unfortunately plutarch doesn't actually
tell us an awful lot about himself for
somebody who's very interested in
narrating stuff we don't get a lot of
biography
from him
what else he uh he becomes a roman
citizen
he has this friend lucius mestrious
flores who is a consul and that's an
important position during uh the reign
of uh vespasian
and um
he and plutarch get connected together
and then plutarch is able to become a
roman citizen now why is that important
why why does that matter
it guarantees you a certain kind of
status you might think back to
um
the new testament and paul right paul is
just some tent maker guy who has a good
education
both on the greek and the hebrew side
turns out to be an important leader
gets in trouble
what does roman citizenship do for him
yeah he doesn't have to be
crucified he got his head cut off well
he not not only that he also has to like
go through he has to be given due
process right whereas people who aren't
roman citizens
well you can cut to the chase right
so you know being a roman citizen has it
has its perks it was also
um you know like a way of entry into
society
as well and so plutarch actually becomes
uh
mestrious plutarchus he takes on his
adopter's name which was the custom at
the time
he writes a lot
the moralia which we'll talk about in
just a moment
there is this catalog of lampreys it was
an ancient list of works and we have a
couple of these ancient lists of works
and they're very tantalizing because we
read all these titles
and then you know we look at what we
have and we're like well where the
hell's that book that's gone it's lost
right and these titles are always really
intriguing you know you know it almost
i'm this is again being facetious it
almost seems like the best stuff
sometimes gets lost and the stuff that
we have is you know the stuff that
everybody's got a copy of this
um it's not it's not the greatest one or
anything
along those lines so according to this
catalog
there were 227 works in the moralia
we don't have anything like that we have
78.
so there was a much larger body of
literature we also know that there are
some lives
parallel lives and lives of the emperors
that were lost as well
so you think about how
much there is of plutarch so there are
if you look at the the moralia right so
this is a lobe edition it's got
greek on one side and english on the
other so if it was all greek it would be
half as thick
14 of these is just the ethical writings
those are not the lives of plutarch
so it was a pretty significant body of
writing you know and you think this
wasn't done with a word processor or
anything like that this is done by hand
you know writing on on scrolls
composing perhaps before time on wax
tablets and then setting things down in
ink he spent an awful lot of time um
doing that
so he goes to rome
eventually
and he you know mixes in with some of
the people there he's he's in rome at a
time when a lot of pretty important
literary figures are there
interestingly he doesn't uh
talk about a lot of them he doesn't seem
to have necessarily connected with them
but we know he was giving lectures and
that people were coming to see him
because he was viewed not just as a you
know cool writer but somebody who had
genuine wisdom
somebody who could you know help you
figure out how to live your life
so he leaves rome and he leaves rome
about the right time um
there were some other philosophers who
had to leave rome shortly after that
epictetus for example the stoic
philosopher dio chrysostom who's kind of
a he's all over the map but he writes a
lot of important stuff particularly
about you know say the cynics
does anybody know why they had to get
out of rome
at that time
this would have been under um
domitian
the emperor
who's kind of a dour
you know he's a
in some ways he was the kind of guy they
needed somebody to get things done
but nobody's friend really
uh he didn't like philosophy and he
thought that you know we should get rid
of these philosophers they they are
basically troublemakers
and he kicked all the philosophers out
of rome he said if you're if you're a
philosopher and you don't get out of
rome we're going to kill you
first and sometimes there'd be things
like we'll shave your beard first or
things like that because beards were
identified with philosophers by that
time but so you know epictetus who is
teaching he said well okay i'll leave
and he goes over to greece um
uh dio cassian goes all over the place
right
and um
[Music]
plutarch you know more or less avoids
that he goes back to
to his home and um one thing i do want
to say about his home at um caronea
it's clear that
people really loved and respected him
he's not only somebody who's wealthy and
his family has a good name
he's somebody who contributed to his
society he took on leadership positions
when when those were expected
um he holds the you know position of
arkhan for for the city which which
would be sort of like city manager
you know
and that's that's a job that is probably
not a lot of fun you know a lot of
headaches and stuff like that
he also has
a library at his uh house and that's
that's an important thing to have in
ancient times i mean we're here in the
this great frank weinberg library right
and so if we wanted to right now we
could like stop talking and go out and
look in the stacks and find cool books
to to read and stuff like that we
view that as sort of like well of course
you know any good little
village or town or city is going to have
a library
i mean we don't often you know realize
just how unusual that is
in ancient times
if you wanted books you had to buy them
yourself or find somebody else who had
them and
you know we find out for example in
cicero's
um
on moral ends book three
it begins with this little vignette
where
he is at i forget whose house he's in
but cicero's there and he's going to the
library and he runs into marcus cato you
know this great stoic philosopher and
and uh military leader
and he says cato what are you doing here
and cato says i'm i'm studying stoic
philosophy i'm checking out the these
texts in the library and then cato says
are you here to study stoic philosophy
and and cicero says no no today i'm
doing aristotle i want to find these
notebooks and so he's in another part of
the library and then they get to talking
and stuff like that
that's the sort of thing that would
happen in ancient times people would
come and use your library right it
wasn't just as a matter of fact there
were people who would buy books just for
show you know how like there's these
people who
you know you can buy fancy leather-bound
volumes and they never crack them open
you can even buy fake leather-bound
volumes right just to put in your your
library
and there are people who do that um this
is the opposite this is a working
library working for philosophy and and
for other things as well i imagine
so
he did that he also
held dinner parties
he also
would meet with people who just came to
see him especially after he writes the
parallel lives because
that's what makes his reputation people
will go and deliberately
visit this you know small this small
town because this really important guy
is living there sort of like people make
pilgrimages to
authors uh
these days right
i've never done that myself but
i've heard some stories from people
about
how great it was or how horrible it was
or surprising there's there's actually
that great story i don't know if any of
you know this
about a kid who hitchhikes down to
florida
to
meet piers anthony
the
sci-fi and fantasy author
and this happened like decades ago
um the kid is now like i don't know his
40s i think and
he he goes down there and he doesn't
like send a letter or anything to say
hey i'm coming to visit because if he
did pierce anthony would have said i'm
getting out of town
this kid just shows up on his doorstop
and says i like your books
now what
and fears anthony helps him out and then
gets him on his way well people would do
that with plutarch although you know in
plutarch's case he would like put him up
and
they could stay for a while and chat
about you know their life and how
screwed up it is and he'd give him some
useful advice and
that was that um
so that that's giving you some idea of
the history that he's
involved in
if you look at these works
so we have you know basically three
kinds of works
he did lives of the roman emperors
from augustus to vitellius we've lost
almost all of that now why would he do
lives of the roman emperors
well
this is where we get to his his project
what what's he doing in writing
biographies i mean think about when
people write biographies today
what are they after
it could be a number of different things
so you could have like a very dry
academic biography
all the proverbial t's crossed
everything is heavily footnoted you you
open up the back and it's just like you
know footnote 631.
and that's nice sometimes you know if
what you're looking for is accuracy and
also putting things in context
that's not the majority of biographies
that people write though is it
what are best sellers like
juicy details yeah
that's a good way to juicy details right
it's and the juicy details
they could be arranged just kind of
salaciously and then he kicked the puppy
down the stairs you know what an awful
guy you know or and then he he found the
orphan who was hobbling along on his
crutch and he gave him a hundred dollar
bill and said go get yourself some
burgers or you know things like that
right
why do we care about these like really
good really bad
sorts of things what are they supposed
to demonstrate to us
what are they yielding intellectually to
us
yeah moral values and behavior what we
could call character and and in ancient
times they articulated this in terms of
virtues and vices you know good
character traits good
bad character traits um leadership you
know was was a big thing as well you
notice that all the people that he's got
in here are in fact people who exercised
power or an authority now some of them
are mythological
so theseus and romulus uh he didn't
write that one first he he that's just
like those are the oldest ones
um and he says you know i'm gonna do a
life of romulus i don't know if the guy
actually existed but
i'll also do you know one for somebody
who is really important for the
establishing of athens that's kind of
similar theseus
and he even says in there a lot of this
stuff that i'm working with is source
materials that's kind of dubious right
but when he gets to other people who you
know we've got a lot more information
about
um you know there he can be a lot more
let's say realistic right think about
the one
where he's comparing
um caesar and alexander the great right
two really really
important in the sense of like
determining world history people
two screwed up guys too i mean alexander
man there's a lot of
dumb things he did over the course of
his lifetime caesar also was not a great
moral paragon
um
he wasn't the worst of people but he was
he was actually pretty bad in many
respects
but they they really accomplish things
another person who's kind of you know
bad in in many respects sola he talks
about there
some
were a bit more admirable
scipio africana so it'd be nice to read
that but unfortunately that biography is
lost
what he's keen to do
is not to try to set down all the events
of the person's life or figure out you
know like sometimes we do biography and
we're like what made this person turn
out the way that they did
you know like when we talk about serial
killers right
what if this person hadn't encountered
this trauma
he's not focused on that he's more
concerned with well what decisions did
these people make how did they show
character or moral values as you said
how do they display that so those are
you know quite useful if we read
plutarch's lives as if they're genuine
history
that's not what he was aiming at
and we we would kind of get you know
how to put it it's you know it it sort
of verges into propaganda
in some respects right
if we treat it as if it's all true
and then there's the moralia
the moralia go ahead going back to the
parallel lives yeah is he objective
though i mean does he talk about people
who have you know moral deficiencies oh
yeah yeah okay okay so he's objective on
this well so that's a good question it
depends on what we mean by objective
right
so if what we mean is that he's kind of
fair and even-handed and he's not going
to um just tell a good story for the
sake of telling a good story then then
yes if we mean like he's
taking a lot of source texts and being
careful with that yeah i mean
but but a lot of a lot of people at that
time weren't doing that
yeah yeah
yeah i mean he he's committed to truth
being a very important value so he's not
going to outright lie about people as a
matter of fact he has so in the moralia
you're going gonna see one of the uh
things is actually about herodotus the
you know so-called father of history
right and he's not the only one to
criticize herodotus for being a liar
here we go on the malice of herodotus
right on the badness the choosing to do
the wrong thing
um herodotus gets kind of a bad rap but
then again if you ever read herodotus
history of the persian wars particularly
book one
you're like yeah i don't know
some of the later stuff this might be
true but i don't know that things
actually happen the way that he's
narrating it about the the causes of the
war
he's trying to be you know more
more clear more more fair but so the
moralia right
there's all these different interesting
sometimes tantalizing if you haven't
read them titles
they cover a ton of stuff but you notice
some common
themes coming up
the emotions
he's got one on envy and hate for
example
as i mentioned the one that got me
started reading plutarch was on
restraining anger he gives you
techniques for understanding
and uh restraining the emotion of anger
that was a big big problem in the
ancient world
almost like today
there's questions about virtue and vice
there's uh you know some
interesting advice given to married
couples
there's a lot of like delving into the
culture of his time as i mentioned
there's an entire volume of table talk
so he's just ranging all over the place
anything that could be of interest for
him
he
works out some thoughts about it and
yeah go ahead number 30 ken virtue were
you taught how did he come down
yeah he thinks it can be taught um you
know and this is a big issue in the
ancient world
it was clear that some people were good
and some people were bad and how can you
make people better and try to wean them
away from their bad tendencies
there are some there are some people
where you just can't do anything
and there is also you can say
for at least for adults they you know
plutarch thinks we have free wills so
you can't like
condition somebody and automatically
make them good
but you know you can you can guide them
you can give them words of advice you
can have them do certain practices like
the anger thing right
one of the things that he talks about
that actually turns out to be kind of
effective and a lot easier to do in our
time
is what's called bringing before the
eyes you get yourself angry and you're
about to say stupid things or do bad
things and you look in a mirror
and you see how out of control you are
your face is red your jaw is clenched
and stuff like that nowadays you can
just like take your phone
and
turn the camera around and you
a selfie right you could actually like
look at yourself when you're angry and
easily do that
he's talking about psychological
techniques where you like visualize what
you look like and
if you do that
provided you don't just say well i love
being angry
that bastard's got it coming right
all the things that we typically say you
can like make yourself less angry and if
you do that over time you can change
your disposition to become to become
better
and so a lot of his advice is uh
circling around those kinds of issues
he also you know has an interest in
literature and
in
familial affection
and you know parsing out what's true and
what's false and so this is a good lead
into talking about philosophy itself
so i mentioned that
he is a what we call a hellenistic
philosopher so it's the time after plato
and aristotle
and it's also the time after the greek
city-states had more or less lost their
independence i mean even the ones that
have relative independence in the roman
empire they're not totally independent
because as soon as they get out of line
rome is going to come in and you know
take control
so
um
that that time was actually one of the
most fruitful times for philosophy
and we have these great philosophical
schools so there's you know the platonus
school starting with plato and then we
have other socratic schools like the
cynics
um antisthenes diogenes crates they they
are
a major thing we have
some hedonistic schools one starts with
a student of socrates but then we have
the epicureans who become one of the
more
dominant schools as well we have
skeptics and the platonic academy will
become skeptical for a while but there's
also a guy pyro who is you know he was
teaching skepticism the stoics put
together a couple different things from
the cynics and the platonic academy and
from another minor school and become
another major school of their own
there's pythagoreans out there floating
around here and there
you know teaching their stuff usually in
in kind of a secretive way
and
there's aristotelians there's all these
things going on
and these schools
are evolving
they don't just you know to be an
aristotelian doesn't mean these you take
aristotle's books and you're like
well the answer's got to be in here
somewhere you know just got to look for
the right verse and aristotle's got
everything covered
they were engaging the other schools
they were thinking out problems that
aristotle himself had left unresolved so
for example alexander of aphrodisias the
guy who's called the commentator
who is in alexandria one of the great
university towns of the time
he um
he works out some things that aristotle
didn't work through
about human freedom and causality and
fate
aristotle you know touched on those
issues and then just kind of moved on
right
and there's a lot of this going on
so platonism
isn't just reading plato's dialogues and
then trying to figure out how you're
going to live a life in accordance with
them it's a broad river of thinkers
down to plutarch's time
and
the platonic academy does take what we
call you know a skeptical turn when we
say skeptical what we mean are people
who
say that we can't actually have reliable
knowledge about everything or even most
things
and there were some
let's call them hardcore skeptics you
know hyperbolic skeptics oh we can't
know anything right so some of them were
saying that and then there were some
more mitigated skeptics like carneades
who said well
you know we can know things not with
certainty but at least with probability
if i poke myself in the eye it's
probably going to hurt i don't actually
have to do it to figure that out every
single time you know we can have what
later on in the in the
early modern period they would call
moral certitude right if you ever read
somebody like david hume he talk he uses
that word a lot and hume is a mitigated
skeptic like that and then the platonic
academy
moves away from skepticism
for a while and there's a really
important guy
antiochus of ascalon who actually taught
cicero
cicero did remain kind of a mitigated
skeptic like a carniary fanboy you could
say
but antiochus steers platonism back to
its roots
to
reading plato and taking on some of the
key ideas and so this is where we get
the middle platonism we have old
platonism
and then we have middle platonism
and then later on what comes out if
you've got old and middle what are you
going to have
new yeah neoplatonism right so platinus
and porphyry and all those those guys
later on in in the third century um
ce
um in the meantime you got you got
plutarch and plutarch is typical
of middle platonism
in that he's kind of eclectic
so when we we use this word eclectic
we mean somebody who they do have a core
they they know what they're doing but
they they're willing to like listen to
other people they're willing to take on
good ideas and so plutarch he's a
platonist but that doesn't mean he has
to reject aristotle he can take good
ideas from aristotle
he's you know a little bit more leery of
the stoics of his time he probably
misunderstands some of the stoics at the
time but he's also willing to take ideas
from them as a matter of fact he's
willing to steal ideas so you know
aristotle in if you only remember one
thing about aristotle's ethics it's the
doctrine of what is it does anyone know
it offhand
the mean the middle you know
yeah virtues are in the middle vices are
on the outside so aristotle came up with
that as far as we can tell plutarch
attributes it to socrates
now why would he do that
well because that makes it platonic it's
a way of taking somebody else's insights
and saying oh i'm not i'm not deviating
from plato
because you know socrates also thought
about this right
well he does that with some of the stoic
stuff the only the only school that he
actually is very hostile to
and many people were at the time is the
epicureans the epicureans are sort of
the bad boys also bad girls there were a
lot of female epicureans
even at the very beginning of the the
garden
and so he doesn't think the epicureans
have much to contribute but he'll take
stuff so like the stoics have a good
idea about the emotions
he's willing to accept some of those
ideas
and he's also
interested in some things as all the the
middle plateaus were
that were less stressed in plato and in
plato's successors
for example you know how screwed up this
world is
and how we can understand evil
and how we can
wean ourselves away from it matter
itself is
understood as something bad plato
thought the body was was bad right
generally in the symposium maybe not so
much but in in the fado and things like
that
and so you know how do things get so
messed up if we've got like a beneficent
god well you know god works with the
crap materials that he has at hand in
his screwed up universe which is matter
and so he's making the best of things
that he can but it's really easy for
things to fall apart you know
another key idea was that of diamonds
these
in-between creatures
well not even really creatures spirits
and this comes up in plato's symposium
a few other places as well this became
incredibly important for middle
platonism
the diamonds are the the in the the
things that go in between us and the
gods
so the gods are you know living this
wonderful life up here we're down here
as schlubs you know eeking out our
existence and then we have these things
that are kind of half and half kind of
in between and you can engage with them
in certain ways
they were also very interested in
freedom of the will and and you know
formulating that as a problem yeah i
just had a question for you you
mentioned um that example of god um
having to deal with the material that he
has yeah um
so
but i don't think they had that concept
of god right at that time i mean like
they
which concept of god
as a creator
plato's uh timaeus has a creator god who
creates the entire universe
so it's it's not it's not something
that's coming just from monotheistic
religions like judaism and later on
christianity um i mean christianity at
the time that plutarch is writing would
be kind of a
small mostly jewish sect um not doing
not
not doing great but not doing poorly not
not you know enjoying the great success
that's going to have later on but yeah i
mean the the plateness
aristotle has speculations about you
know is the universe eternal is it
created this is something that was being
thought of the stoics you might actually
find this interesting just one sec so
the stoics had this this concept of what
they called the apoirosis which means
that the whole universe would burn up
it would like be converted into fire
and then you know everything would be
over and then it would start up again
right so you've got like a whole new
let's call it a whole new creation
although it turns out it's exactly the
same as the previous one right what were
you gonna ask go ahead yeah so
so do they think that they they've got
do they deal with the guys that we know
of from like good giver yes and so
it helps sometimes i think
to um
imagine an uppercase g god
like the god right and you can call it
zeus if you want it you can call it
apollo but it's the top top thing
and then there's all these lowercase g
gods
that do specific things
and they don't do them you know i mean
platonous
allegorize gods
because you know there's all these
stories about like zeus screwing around
on his wife
and um the gods fighting in the trojan
war fighting each other and hermes
stealing from other gods and i mean we
could go on and on dionysus gets drunk
aphrodite's trying to get everybody in
bed with each other you know they're
kind of a messy bunch
and so they would say well you know the
gods aren't really like that that's what
the poets made them out to be
um you know what is aphrodite she's the
force of love you know what is uh aries
he's the force of
anger or hatred or war or something like
that and and we can understand these in
ways that get away from all those crazy
stories right
so that that's what the platonist and
the stoics too by the way we're we're
into the epicureans believe it or not
did believe in gods
they just thought that the gods had
nothing to do with human beings and
that's why the gods were blessed
you know they lived in some
other dimension or other world doing
their own god thing that had no
connection to us and so you know you
might say well what the hell good are
those you know and the epicureans would
say precisely you know we don't have any
we don't have any connection with them
but for the platoonists
um having the right conception of the
gods was was quite important as a matter
of fact um
plutarch has a piece that tells us a lot
about ancient egyptian religion isis and
osiris
and he looks like he may have traveled
in egypt
and asked people about about worship and
things there and he's doing something
kind of similar he's saying the
egyptians do this and this and this and
this and here's what they believe here's
the real story you know here's what's
really going on in that
so
you could call it a
philosophically transformed concept of
god
right
it's refined maybe you could say
but it's it's still kind of pessimistic
the world is crap it's made out of
matter
uh you know there's other things besides
matter but
god's got to work with the materials
he's got i mean you don't have anything
like
saying
as you could later on well why the hell
didn't god make better materials you
know
god god's a little powerful there's no
idea of like creation ex nihilo
as we see like in christian theology
later on
it's you create with the stuff you've
got at hand
and um you know they don't actually ask
the question well where did that stuff
come from
you know
so they don't believe in the whole
penalty of greek god
did you say again i don't believe in the
whole finale of recast well yes and no i
mean he believed that there were gods
and that there were stories about them
and the stories were all mostly bs
i mean this is why he wants to kick the
poets out of the city in in republic
book two and three and then comes back
to them in book ten because the poets
lie
the poets tell us stuff about the gods
that wouldn't be true if the gods are
actual good gods and you know you could
ask you could actually say to somebody
like plato well how the hell do you know
that they're good gods you know how do
you know that the poets aren't right you
know and i think that's a legitimate um
uh response what are your family then
oh so aristotle um
you know
it's tricky
he he thinks that um the gods are
connected with the heavens and there's
different accounts about just how many
they are there are
and that's basically what they do is
they manage that stuff they don't like
they don't like come down to earth and
have sex with mortal people and have
love affairs and things like that but he
doesn't talk much about it you know i
mean we're kind of handicapped in that
um
we've lost some of the stuff that
aristotle wrote you know and we've lost
even more of the people who came after
him as well
but the aristotelians they seem much
more interested in
our own moral development
and they're less they're less you know
the same with the plaintiffs same with
the stones they're not you don't place a
lot on the gods the gods are good
examples for you
but you don't rely upon them you don't
pray to them hey make me a good person
or something like that you make yourself
a good person
right
epicureans don't even pray at all so
what no which is not to say that most
people in ancient times were following
philosophy you know um
many people were still
engaging in in worship oftentimes very
um
um what would you call it you know you
know like the old expression you know
you go to church on sunday you hear the
good sermon and then on monday you're
back to being the kind of jerk that you
were you know now you got to pray oh god
get me out of this situation
i think there are a lot of people like
that in ancient times too they go and
offer stuff at the temples oh jupiter
make me a good father and then you know
then they'd go be a bad father and then
they'd come back to the temple again and
you know maybe sometimes they got better
maybe sometimes they didn't
i mean this is very speculative to say
all this but
um so anyway
he's heavily involved in the philosophy
of his time he is one of the most
important middle plateaus that we have
there are there's plenty of other ones
that you know
el canoas writes a cool handbook of
platonism that is still survived to this
day
we have other people like apolaus if
you've ever read the golden ass he's
actually a platonist
middle platonus philosopher and then
afterwards we move into neoplatonism
which
is a bit more
deliberately metaphysical
and
starts to
you know sort of sort out how you can
have you know a platonus sort of top
level thing and then stoics and
aristotelians providing you accounts of
the world so a different kind of
eclecticism going on there but plutarch
fits in in there
and i'll you know before we jump into
his influence i'll just say this
many academic philosophers in the last
say
two centuries
have um
dismissed all that they said that's just
derivative
it's you know eclectic is a bad word
you're not being purely platonous you're
not being purely aristotelian
and
this is a set of sort of dogmatic
assumptions on their part i actually
wrote a kind of facetious piece saying
that
alexander of aphrodisias is actually a
better aristotelian than aristotle
himself
in part because he answers questions
aristotle doesn't and he can respond to
people that aristotle didn't have a
chance to
argue with like the epicureans or the
stoics right
i also in that piece argued that
plutarch is a better plateness than
plato himself
because he's got similar opportunities
he delves into things using plato
um but he adds some new ideas of his own
and he engages the stoics and the
epicureans and the skeptics that's
there's something to that that's not
just being derivative that's not just
being a knockoff
and to say that to dismiss them and not
study them sets up a kind of
vicious circle
you don't study them why not because
they're not worth studying
well how do you know that they're not
worth studying
you don't because you don't study them
similar things happen in translation too
by the way where you know why is why is
this stuff not translated these
hellenistic philosophers
well because if they were important they
would already be translated and so we
know that they're not important so we
don't have to translate them
this is bad
logic right
it's a bad way of doing inquiry but
that's the way that that a lot of um
people have have uh treated these
hellenistic philosophers
now influence
um i mentioned you know that that uh
plutarch's works were essentially lost
in in after antiquity they circula
circulated around a lot during antiquity
but they're written in greek
and so as there's fewer and fewer greek
speakers
in the latin west
there's fewer and fewer
reasons to
you know copy out these texts
and
they don't get translated into latin
until much later
if they'd been translated into latin
maybe they could have had an important
role in the middle ages
you can just imagine what middle age
people would have done with these cool
stories or some of these moral
treaty sees about things
but as it turns out um plutarch is
largely lost in in the west until the
renaissance the early on in the
renaissance and you know where are they
getting these texts some of the
renaissance texts were recovered from
monasteries
where the monks you know they didn't
know what was in their libraries um and
you know these scholars go in there and
they're like holy crap look at this
and then they bring it out and that's
great a lot of them are coming from the
fall of the eastern roman empire as the
ottomans are closing in and destroying
it
all these scholars are like this is not
a good place for me to stick around you
know i'm going to go west and where do
they go mostly to italy and that's one
of the reasons why these texts
and not just plutarch but you know
marcus aurelius
all sorts of important philosophers
get recovered and now they're being read
by people and they get translated into
other languages latin i mentioned
italian french english
and
once they're translated these lives
become
really interesting to a lot of people
the morali lesso unfortunately
um but the lives
end up influencing
shakespeare um john dryden
actually began a life of flutark and
then he oversaw a translation of the
lives
jean-jacques rousseau you know cites
plutarch and emile
boswell quoted plutarch on writing lives
rather than biographies
he influences alexander hamilton john
milton edmund burke
mark twain all sorts of people
beethoven when he's got when he's
growing deaf he's he writes i've also
i've often cursed my creator in my
existence plutarch
has shown me
the way of resignation if it's at all
possible i will bid defiance to my fate
though i feel as long as i live there
will be moments when i shall be god's
most unhappy creature resignation
tranquility
what a wretched resource yet that that
is all that is left to me
ralph waldo emerson also influenced
considerably
by plutarch the transcendentalists
and some backing up a little bit
somebody else who i'm a big fan of
really thought plutarch was important
along with cicero probably his two most
important people
miguel de montan
if you've ever read his essays
lots and lots of plutarch in those as a
matter of fact
some people think his style is indebted
to plutarch's style
so
plutarch is very influential until as i
mentioned the beginning of the 19th
century
when we get this idea that is associated
with you know i mentioned we're going to
talk about
hegel later on hegel is one of the
people who unfortunately puts this idea
out that when the greek city-states are
no longer independent you can really no
longer have
first-rate philosophy
you're not doing great metaphysics
you're just doing this kind of
derivative philosophy as a way of life
stuff
this is a mistaken idea
about hellenistic philosophy
and it's it's always even wrong about
plato and aristotle played on aerosol
we're doing philosophy as a way of life
all ancient philosophy was tied in with
this this conception of something that
you would live out
so plutarch is one of the heavy hitters
who
you know i i would say we should be
reading a lot more of
we can read the lives they're really
great you know i'm a big fan of people
doing that but there's already plenty of
high school and college teachers telling
people to read them anyway right
i think we should be going back to the
moralia and checking out some of these
things that he has to say
about all sorts of topics i mean he
might be wrong about some but at least
we we get an idea
about um how to approach
the passions anger
marriage warfare you know conflict
how to structure our lives
some of them might not be as useful
these days like
you know things about delphi why there's
an e at delphi
okay that's a little obscure
but a lot of these things are still
pretty
helpful
for our um lives that we're living today
in the you know
interconnected mobile technology age i
would say
so that that's basically all i've got to
say for my notes but i'm happy to
field any questions and you know
go whatever
paths of conversation you'd like to go
down yeah why do um some of the titles
include pseudo coupon oh
that's a good question so pseudo
plutarch means it ain't plutarch it's
somebody else pretending to be plutarch
this this is a very common phenomena in
ancient and medieval writing
so i'll just give you an example of
somebody in the medieval times um one
guy who i do work on anselm of
canterbury
he was very popular and he wrote a lot
of really interesting
rhetorically
worked out prayers
probably wrote about 13 or 14 of them
in the middle ages people would write a
prayer and they'd they'd be like
nobody's actually going to listen to me
i'll say this is by handsome
and then they'd send it out and then
some poor sap would be like another hand
sell me in prayer let me copy this out
there were a hundred prayers attributed
to anselm that weren't actually by him
plutarch doesn't have as many right but
there are some things that that the
scholars say these are not by plutarch
these are
these are by somebody else we're not
quite sure you know aristotle has some
works like that the
uh economics we're not really sure if
that's aristotle the magnum moralia
we're not sure if that's by him the pro
oh so that's a good question um
can you ever know for certain
no but you can have again probability
you can look at the style
right and you can say
this is written in a kind of different
size it's sort of like when we
professors we have students who try to
plagiarize
and they always get caught why do they
get caught because the writing goes
from like a magisterial thing down to
whatever level their writing is at uh
within like a paragraph you're like come
on this ain't by you and then what you
do is you take a string of the good
stuff you put it in google and then you
see exactly what website they took it
from
so it's not it's not that easy with um
you know philosophical
things from antiquity but you can say
well
it's you know here'd be a really uh good
one if it's referencing something that
happened after the philosopher died
right that's a dead giveaway um but you
know stylistic things that that can be a
way to do it but that that does make it
kind of dicey right because one person's
different style might be another
person's this is a a variant they're
writing a different way because they're
talking about something different so we
never we never completely know right in
the case of some of these philosophers
there's by the way there's platonic
dialogues that are thought to be
spurious in the same way um
you know there's and this this goes on
into the modern period too
what's that shakespeare yeah yeah i mean
and it's kind of funny because if
there's that theory like oh this isn't
by shakespeare this is by who bacon
and
bacon had a guy working for him that
some other people think
bacon stuff isn't really bi it's
actually by hobbs it wouldn't be a real
kick in the pants you know but i mean
the likelihood of that is very low but
um yeah there's there's all i mean
i'll also i'll tell you this i've ghost
written stuff myself in the course of my
career
um you know so if if i've done it
there's probably got to be
hundreds of thousands of people out
there doing it you know we know that a
lot of people who have their own
best-selling book they didn't write that
book you know they had a ghostwriter do
it for them and that's how it got on the
new york times bestseller list because
they're not
a good enough writer to tell their story
right so but that's a little bit
different than pseudonym
what's the i always get this word mixed
up suit suit anonymous um or pseudo uh
writings of plutarch or something like
that but it's kind of a fascinating
topic isn't it
what did he have to say about the eating
of flesh was he oh
yeah
and and this
so this is a little bit of trivia but
in the ancient world
vegetarianism was particularly
associated with pythagoreanism
pythagoras
there were a couple other things you
weren't you weren't supposed to eat
beans either
nobody's quite sure why
there's a lot of theories right
but the pythagoreans thought you
shouldn't eat flesh and the reason you
shouldn't is because reincarnation
happens so that might be your grandpa
that you're eating you know
so
um
you know some some philosophers were
influenced by this there were other
philosophers
who had other
arguments against eating meat there was
a guy named sextus in rome who had his
own little school that we don't know
much about other than from seneca
and he had a different rationale for not
eating meat that basically had not being
cruel to to the animals and stuff like
that
and plutarch it's not like he was a
consistent vegetarian where you know he
made that all about what he did all the
time but it looks like he probably was
a vegetarian and so
you know there's some
there's some really interesting dietary
stuff in ancient philosophy
some of which
again like why did the pythagoreans not
eat beans
we don't know you know we just knew that
they thought it was really important you
know
not to do that
so
yeah well off topic but um you said
yesterday airstyle plato would be
aristotle was more of a realist and
plato more idealist is that kind of
different so that's a thumbnail sketch
that we often give but it turns out not
to be all that accurate when we go to
their works
plato definitely did believe that there
were
transcendent forms that that don't exist
in material things that material things
are copies of them and you and i are for
example copies of human being as is
everybody else in here
and the ideal human being
doesn't have gender doesn't you know
have skin color doesn't have any of
those sorts of things
so there's a whole um
whatever we want to call it uh invisible
uh
non-sensory intelligible world that's
where the idealist thing comes in right
yeah but plato thought we also see a
chair
so he's also a realist there is a real
chair there it's just not as real as the
form you know and aristotle himself um
is pretty platonic in many respects a
lot of when we teach philosophy like an
intro class or in a textbook we often
try to give this like there's this big
dividing line between the two of them
but it's much more like they're
overlapping a lot and then aristotle's
got some more stuff on this side and
plato's got some more stuff on on this
side i mean one place where it would
really make a difference so
plato thought that we had a soul
that is
different than the body and when the
body dies the soul
goes on and you know he's got a bunch of
different stories about how this works
and you can kind of piece them together
um
it it you know gets reincarnated
eventually
um it gets to see the forms you know
there's all sorts of different accounts
right if it's really bad it gets put
into like a wolf's body or something
like that if you're a philosopher and
you get reincarnated three times and
you've been a really good one you you
don't have to be reincarnated anymore
and you get to go hang out with the gods
and stuff like that
aristotle thinks
your soul
is your body it's the structure of your
body it's the form of your body it's
what keeps your body from being medical
waste
and
when the body dies
that's pretty much it for the soul
you know um then he hedges and he says
well maybe there's a part of the soul
that's actually immortal but
you know here we get into really really
speculative stuff where aristotle didn't
say enough about it and then later
aristotelians are like
i think he meant this and then other
ones are like no no no he must have
meant this instead and there's a lot of
disagreement between them
but yeah i mean there's there's a lot of
overlap between
between these different philosophers
they're you know they're all concerned
with
how do we um unscrew ourselves up that's
like a really central question
how do we move ourselves away from bad
stuff to good stuff you know
and if you if you bring them together
this is part of what plutarch is doing
in his eclecticism
if you bring together the various
traditions you wind up with something
much more powerful
right it so this is a little bit of a
rant on my part there's a lot of people
in the present who because there's a lot
of people getting into philosophy as a
way of life and they're like i'm on team
stoic you know stoic everything for me
screw the aristotelian screw the
plateness screw the epicarions
that's not a proper stoic position
if you look at the actual stoics like
seneca
or epitidus or the originator of it who
was himself bringing together multiple
strains
if they if somebody else had something
good to contribute you take that on
right it'd be sort of like being a
musician and being like
i only play the jugs no other musical
instrument you know and somebody's got a
violin and you're like don't get that
away from me you know no
it could be nice to have a violin in
there or something so i kind of think
that plutarch and
cicero and people like that are actually
better philosophers because they're able
to bring together these multiple
strains and think through what they want
to accept
and want to reject you know
yeah
is he known really for any political
philosophy philosophy because i see
number 56 on monarchy democracy oh yeah
that's like a that's like a comparative
thing i mean that doesn't get
it doesn't get really referenced or read
much
um
most of his stuff is you could say it's
more about
um
morals and relationships and stuff like
that than it is about big picture
political stuff but
on the other hand
who does he write his lives about
they're they're mostly people who are
involved in
politics in the
the sense of like organizing societies
right and and handling
really important tasks like the
mysticallys helps handle you know
wartime stuff
so
looks like we're running out of juice on
that
um
i i kind of think uh
again he's sort of an untapped resource
you know it would be nice to have more
right
than uh what we typically get
yeah
sure has anybody ever taken
i guess it's the moralia pick and picked
out the ones that are applicable to
today's life and just kind of
oh i don't know more of a condensed uh
that's a good question um
you know
application to today's life
i don't think so
um
there is a penguin
like plutarch's essays and it's got a
bun it's got a bunch of the the moralia
in it
and there's like little forwards by the
the person who i think translated them
you know this is applicable to this and
that but it's only and it's only about
like this thick so it's obviously just a
very small selection
has anybody like
made a new
contemporary
reinterpretation like a systematic
reinterpretation of plutarch i don't
know anybody who has
and
that might be actually a really good
thing to do
[Music]
you know nowadays it's more like
stoicism is really big
cynicism is kind of big epicureanism is
big there's always been aristotelians
out there doing stuff
there are some um
people trying to take you know socrates
or plato and
and do that as well
but i don't see too many people doing it
not just with with plutarch but also
like with cicero or these other
hellenistic philosophers
i mean the trouble is
this is going to sound very cynical
the trouble is is that
you would have to get either an academic
press
or
a big trade publisher interested in your
idea
and
they you first you'd have to like lie to
them and say oh yeah everybody's
interested in plutarch right uh because
you have to put together like a book
proposal and they'll probably see
through that
you know because not everybody isn't
interested in flute check but let's say
you managed to get it past that
then you got to deal with these editors
who are like can you uh you know
just give us some juicy stuff
and you know i need a thought like a
little bubble here
and
there's
there's just so many hoops you'd have to
jump through i mean you could
self-publish it right that's another
possibility
but um
that's you know it's a lot of work
you know you don't know whether it's
going to pay off or not so
but it would be cool to do it yeah
i'm curious about the idea of
reincarnation oh yeah so obviously he
believed in it yeah
you know indians believe in it yeah
are these ideas that grew up in parallel
or yes
there is no historical connection it's
it's something that we find in multiple
cultures celtic peoples also believed in
reincarnation so it's something that
arises independently
at different places where it gets really
interesting though is when
greeks start running into indians
right
and you've got different traditions that
already have the same idea and they're
like oh you you buy that too
what do you have to say about it right
so or or
cases like
where because of buddhism coming to
china and then to you know korea japan
vietnam vietnam as a result people come
to believe in it as well right and then
you can have all sorts of really
interesting cultural
exchanges taking place
you know i mean you can kind of say that
you know philosophy
develops
um independently in the greek roman
world
within the persian world
within india within the chinese cultural
sphere
and you know all these these really
vast traditions develop in each of those
and then you know christianity islam
judaism to a lesser extent um
develop their own things going on where
they they take aristotle and run with it
or the neoplatonus or something like
that and then bring in biblical
revelations
so you know we can talk about the
islamic world as well and
all of these are
um
independently growing except for the
islamic world in the western world and
the islamic world and the indian
exchange as well
until
the silk road comes in
right and um ideas start to
flow across all these things
and i i would say that by you know the
1500s we can no longer talk about
totally independent traditions you know
the jesuits are there in china
already before they manage to get
themselves kicked out by being a little
bit too
welcoming towards chinese ideas right
and being willing to call
heaven god and stuff like that
but there's these these interchanges
already taking place um and so to go
back to reincarnation
there's all sorts of ideas of it right
and and different cultures can
develop it along different lines that
often look very similar to each other
you can say this in the greek and roman
world it was kind of a minority view
they were much more interested in like
were you going down to hell or going to
the heavens or whatever that was going
to be right
whereas like in india
it became
let's call it the definitive view right
in hinduism buddhism jainism
the other indian religions of that time
that actually die out but had a lot of
followers they all believe in
reincarnation the only only people who
didn't were these materialists who look
kind of like epicureans
the carvakas right
and they were a tiny minority despised
by everyone just like the epicureans
um
so yeah
that's curious that there's so many
different religions that
in order to have reincarnation you have
to have a soul yeah yeah i'm curious
that so many different cultures came up
with the idea of a soul
yeah something that lasts beyond your
death right something that could
not only
endure but also
continue to be you
continue to like have moral
characteristics and deserve punishment
or
reward and all those sorts of things
that's yeah it's a complicated concept
right
um you you had a question
your previous classes
oh so if you google gregory sadler right
that'll take you to my you you'll just
gregory's out there youtube you'll find
my youtube channel
the series is is in a playlist called
philosophers in the midst of history
so yeah and we've got like
17 i think in there
because we had four years and then we
had the one
one-off in 2020. yeah
on the parallel lives i mean and i i
don't know if history's necessary to do
this but were these were these people
alive or were they dead
when he uh oh they're all dead they were
all dead yeah yeah
no that's
that's kind of a funny question though
because you could have somebody maybe
who thought he was being mean to caesar
right caesar
he didn't have any like living
partisans at the time but
i mean you could imagine that somebody
could get angry with him for that but i
think most people viewed him as being
you know
pretty fair
you know
um but yeah i mean that would be kind of
funny if uh somebody wrote on on
plutarch in his terrible histories
where are you where are you going to say
well
yeah
i i just remember this once he's talking
about where his brutal buddhists or
somebody
he's
somebody said blah blah blah blah blah
and that may be true
but that probably was not because
so-and-so says this and that that's more
in character
yeah
so
yeah i mean i think he's trying to be
he's trying to get at the truth and that
involves
listening to a lot of people's stories
some of which may be like complete
smears
or what would be the opposite of a smear
like you know glowing recommendations
and
um
i mean it's the same sort of thing as we
have to do today when we're assessing
character right it's not like we have
any pure sources
even within families
you can like be well that person's just
a jerk and then you know somebody takes
you aside and they're like well you
gotta understand this happened to them
and
this is what they're thinking and
they're like oh okay no now i get it you
know
so
his idea so many were psychopaths at
that time yeah
yeah well you know actually
that makes me think going back to your
question
why write about people who are dead why
not write about the people who are the
movers and shakers at the time
maybe it's easier to figure out the dead
because there's less psychophants
muddying the waters
right
i hadn't thought of that but
yeah i think we'll see if their full
life too
that's true yeah question unrelated sure
topic um i'm just curious um so my son
is a philosophy major right now where uw
madison oh good yeah so what
he's also a computer science major like
a double major so
what can that boy do with his life as a
oh all sorts all sorts of stuff without
it
yeah yeah i mean
so you know
it's interesting that he's got that
combination because back back when i was
majoring in philosophy i was philosophy
in mathematics and in the 1980s and
early 1990s lots of philosophy people
were getting sucked up as analysts
system analysts you know especially if
you had a math degree or computer
science degree
that's you know that landscape has
changed now but there's there's still a
lot of recruitment that goes on
yeah oh yeah definitely and and you know
um philosophy students score the highest
on the lsats as a group for going to law
school
really in the humanities in general so
you know philosophy
history
literature all these sorts of things
you can move into a variety of other
fields you've got to have done something
else so obviously they're not going to
like oh wow you've got a philosophy
degree cool we're going to hire you now
but if you've got some background so you
know for example my wife over there andy
she
she and i are
both philosophers
she's also worked for the culinary
institute of america first as
a dean and as an instructor and
now she's actually a contractor working
with them so there's all these
connections between that andy could i
mean she could actually throw out a few
examples between philosophy and the food
sphere like food ethics you know or you
know
they do a lot of work with
entrepreneurship philosophy can be
involved in that figuring out
how to see your way from
um
to the end that you want picking the
right means that's something that
philosophy not only philosophy
psychology can help you with that other
other fields can too but philosophy if
it's done right it can really if it you
know the training can help with that and
i'll tell you one of the other things
that i do as a consultant
is unless andy wants to chime in with
with any examples okay
the other roles that both of us have is
we teach for milwaukee institute of art
and design oh yeah i teach service
learning courses on food waste
challenges for artists and designers
and you know philosophical efforts are
certainly key but what's really been
impressing me is the new studio practice
students are doing philosophical inquiry
about the artistic practice yeah looking
at emerging philosophical themes and how
that actually influenced the art that
was being created at that time or
innovation in that space so
i agree though it's an excellent
foundation
yeah i mean it's he's not gonna unless
he
says
i'm only gonna be a philosophy professor
he'll be very employable you know if he
decides he wants to be a philosophy
professor well there's not a lot of jobs
but oh god it can be really bad for a
parent i know
bad for a parent yeah because my
daughter has a bachelor and master's in
philosophy are you talking about liz
yeah just like i did okay so then she
went and had free ride to law school the
first year made more money i ever made
money oh yeah
so it's unfair i didn't know that she
had a
philosophy degree oh yeah yeah that's
cool yeah well thanks for everybody and
uh
yeah
i'm glad we could we could do this again
you